chérie maman qu'est-ce que c'est que je dois aller avec
Roy
on m'a dit d'emmener un homme à l'hôtel j'ai dit
qu'il était un ennemi de l'état
enlève ta robe
et en échange ma mère pourrait avoir le
médecin dont elle avait besoin à la place ils lui ont coupé la
gorge
il ne pouvait y avoir aucun témoin alors ils m'ont donné le
choix de mourir ou de devenir un moineau à partir de
ce jour vous deviendrez
des armes spatiales dans une lutte mondiale pour le
pouvoir vous serez formé à la
manipulation psychologique vous devez apprendre à
vous pousser au-delà de toute limitation prendre  enlève
tes vêtements quand nous en aurons fini avec
toi la personne que tu étais n'existera plus
chaque être humain est un puzzle de
besoin tu dois devenir la pièce manquante
et ils te diront tout ce que tu as
un cadeau tu sais comment survivre c'est
ce que tu  étaient censés faire
qui est un traître au gouvernement son
dernier contact connu est un américain
vêtements morts je suis un pharisien dans la piscine
hier
allons-nous devenir amis dites ce que
vous voulez
c'est un moineau le seul américain de
quoi  tu peux faire pour eux travailler avec moi
et faire payer cet homme tu vaux
mieux que n'importe lequel d'entre nous ton seul problème est que
tu as une âme à laquelle
nous ne pouvons pas faire confiance dans un mot qui sort
de sa bouche il y a autre chose que
nous sommes maintenant  voyant
qu'elle est compromise elle sera éliminée
qu'as-tu fait
tu leur appartiens ils ne lâcheront jamais
je trouverai un moyen
toi